Even though I walked through the valley of the shadow of death. I
will not fear for you are with me. You are
my light and my salvation.
You restore me and Lead Me For Your Glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Well, good morning everyone. Hey, that
was pretty good.
As Ryan mentioned last week was
spring break which is why many of our students
were on a mission trip.
And although I don't have kids that
are still in school. I had spring break last week as
well. My wife and I took the week off
and we did some really exciting things. We got
to do things like clean out gutters trim
trees paint have Plumbing
work done at our house all kinds
of really fun stuff. So it was a very
restful week.
But today we're going to look at Psalm 54.
And I'm gonna go ahead and invite you to
go ahead and get your Bibles out whether you have printed copy
or digital copy. Go
ahead and get them out get them ready get to that spot and we'll be using
that in just a minute.
But as I studied for this message, I started
looking for some stories from
people who had come to
the end of their resources.
And they had nothing left.
But to ask God to do something that only he
could do.
And I came across this story about Dallas Theological
Seminary.
And so it goes like this in 1924
Dallas Theological Seminary
almost went bankrupt.
And on the day that it was supposed to be foreclosed on at
noon.
Dr. Harry Ironside the president of the
Seminary at the time held a prayer
meeting in his office.
And that day Dr. Ironside prayed a
prayer that he had prayed many many times before.
But on this day, he prayed it like this. It says Lord,
we know that the cattle on a thousand hills
are thine.
Please sell some of them and give us the money.
Makes sense, right?
So as he prayed with some staff
and faculty there a tall Texas oil
man walked into the receptionist office
and he said I just sold
two carloads full of
cattle.
You see where this is going, don't you?
And he said I've been trying to make this business deal
work and it just won't it won't go through.
So I feel compelled to give this money to the
Seminary.
He goes, I don't know if you really need this or not. But here's the
check.
the receptionist jumped up ran in and burst
into the room where everybody was praying and said Harry
God just sold the cattle.
Now Dr. Ironside and his staff they
were desperate.
They were out of resources and the bank was going to
come call it.
And he and them were completely dependent
upon God.
And God came through.
And he did it with style.
One of our values as a church is that we rely on
the Holy Spirit to empower our lives and
the church as we humbly abide in
Jesus.
Recognizing that we can do nothing apart from
him.
Have you ever found yourself in a situation? Were you
have exhausted all of your resources?
You got nothing left?
How are you going to solve a problem that you have?
No resources for?
You're destitute you're desperate.
And you're utterly dependent on someone else.
To get you out of trouble.
Psalm 54 David gives us a perfect example
Of what desperate dependence is
supposed to look like?
Now I didn't set out to preach a sermon on one of
our values. This is just the psalm. That was next.
But this Psalm really spoke to my life and it
it very quickly became obvious
that this was one of
those psalms that just exemplified what it
looks like to live out this value in our lives.
So I asked you to open up your Bible. So let's let's go
there to Psalm 54 and we're going to read God's
word together.
Now there's a line at the beginning of
this Psalm before you get to the actual verses. I'm gonna
go ahead and read that it may or may not be in your Bible. But
then I'll talk about it here in a minute. So that
line says to the choir Master with
stringed instruments a mask of David.
When the zephites went and told Saul is not David hiding
Among Us.
Verse 1. Oh God, Save Me by your name
and vindicate me by your might o God
here my prayer.
Give ear to the words of my mouth for strangers have
risen against me.
Ruthless men seek my life.
They do not set God before themselves. Say la.
Behold God is my helper.
And the Lord is the upholder of my life.
He will return the evil to my enemies and your
faithfulness put an end to them.
With a free will offering I sacrifice to you.
I will give thanks to your name O Lord for
it is good.
For he has delivered me from every trouble.
And my eye has looked in Triumph on
my enemies.
So looking at this Psalm that opening line
is what's known as a superscript.
And that's just an informational line that gives us
more details about what's to come.
So the first thing that we see is that this is written
to the choir Master with stringed instruments.
So this just means that the author intended that
this be sung in a corporate setting with
accompanying instruments.
And next is it's a mask goal of David David.
In this case is the soon-to-be king
of Israel.
What's a maskel?
I'm glad you asked.
A mask who is just a literary term that means to instruct
or make perceivable.
This Psalm was not only to be used in a
corporate worship setting but it was intended to
instruct God's people.
And I pray that it instructs us today.
Next it references the zephites.
Telling Saul that David's hiding Among
Us.
This reference gives us direct insight to what's going on
in David's life as he wrote this
and we know that this reference is to first
saw a first Samuel 23.
So what happened to David that it would
Inspire him to write this?
Well this first Samuel 23 is the
account of David going to
the aid.
of the city of kiela
Now I'm certain that I mispronounced that I tried
the Hebrew pronunciation in my Bible software and you're
just going to get the Oki version.
Got no shot.
So David was told that the
Philistines were attacking and robbing the city of
kiela.
And so David sought the Lord and asked if
he should go and attack the Philistines.
And the Lord answered him. Yes.
But David's men were afraid.
So David sought the Lord a second time.
And the Lord responds to David once again.
He says that he will deliver the Philistines into
their hands.
So David does his Lord instructs and he
goes and he attacks and defeats the
Philistines and saves the city.
but in doing this David catches the attention of Saul
who is actually seeking to kill David at the time because he
was a threat to the throne of Israel.
So Saul plots to send an
army to the city of kiela.
And trap David in the city because this was
a city that had walls and
Gates and Saul knew that if he could get there
and trap David inside.
He would have them.
David Gets wind of this plot of Saul
and
once again, he cries out to the Lord.
and the Lord replies
And assures David that he should in fact go he should
leave.
Otherwise the city that he just saved.
Would certainly turn him and his men over to Saul's
Army.
So David and his men they flee Into the Wilderness.
when
Saul heard that David had escaped he gave
up his plot.
So if you want to know more about what happened between David
and Saul
go and read first Samuel 23 and
24. It truly is one of the great stories
of the Bible and how God
perseveres.
So in Psalm 54, we have three sections.
And the first of these three sections is verses 1
through 3.
And this represents David's cry for help.
Verse 1 says oh God Save Me by your name and vindicate
me by your might who God hear my
prayer give ear to the words of my mouth for
strangers have risen against me ruthless men
seek my life.
They do not set God before themselves.
say la sala is just a word that calls our
attention that there's something that we should stop and meditate
on and focus on and give our
attention to
So verses 1 and 2 David says save me.
Help me.
And in the first Samuel account David sought the Lord and
he cried out to God to save him.
from The Strangers
Okay.
He knew and he deeply believed that God
would save him.
Just as he had before.
David knows that God is the only one that can
help him.
And we know just as David did that God
is our rescuer.
Our Redeemer our protector
and our sustainer
think about this.
David was being hunted by Saul the
king of Israel.
That's not good.
That's really really bad.
think of this in terms of
the president and the Armed Forces of
the United States hunting you
That's almost certainly you're going to
get caught and killed, right?
You got no chance.
Saul's Army intended to find David
and kill him and his men.
We may not have somebody out to kill us.
But often we do have enemies, don't we?
And they try and do us harm. Maybe even destroy us
destroy our reputations.
We've all had somebody who was out to get us.
And trying to cause us hardship.
have your souls
been fellow Christians
How painful is that?
The answer is it's horribly painful.
People that are supposed to love and care for you attacking you.
What's that about?
Is this really how we're supposed to treat each other?
Oh Jesus and John 13 34
and 35 has something to say about that.
It says a new commandment. I give to you that you
love you have love for one
another just as I have loved you.
You are also to love one another by this
all people.
will know
that you are my disciples.
if you have love for one another
we're supposed to love each other not attack each
other.
But this Brokenness this hatred and jealousy.
Where people seek to do harm to each other for no good
reason.
Is why God had to send his son to die for our
sins.
Jesus had to pay the price for our wickedness.
If you've ever been attacked in this way.
You've probably experienced deep hurt.
This kind of hurt it stays with you for
a lifetime.
If that's ever happened to you, I am really really
sorry.
It shouldn't be that way.
It's happened to me.
More than I care to think about.
And it happened to David.
You see verse 3 says that for strangers
have risen against me.
The zephites are actually The Strangers that David is referring
to here.
And they were known in maybe in some of your translations that
uses these words as ruthless and Violent
Men.
but
these people were not strangers at all.
They were fellow Israelites.
The word for strangers here in Hebrew just refers
to someone or something.
That is foreign to the
community where it's standards.
These men weren't strangers to David's
Nation, but they were strangers to
the faith that they were supposed to share.
They were not part of the true Israel.
The Apostle Paul was one of the most highly thought about
the thought of Jews until he met Jesus.
Romans 28 or 2:28 and 29 says
for no one is a Jew who is
merely one outwardly.
Nor is circumcision outward and physical.
But a Jew is one inwardly and circumcision is
a matter of the heart.
by the spirit
not by the letter.
His praise is not from man, but from God.
These men weren't just betraying David.
They were betraying their faith.
and God
how Despicable
how outrageous
That these men would act this way.
They were supposed to be brothers.
Wait a minute.
Let's flip this around.
Are you?
The Saul in someone else's story
I know that one stings.
It stung me.
Have you ever been so mad about something or at
someone that you went on the attack against
them?
Maybe you didn't attack them directly. Maybe you just attack them to
other people.
If we're honest
most of us probably have
My point is this.
If we can identify with David.
We should be honest.
And identify with Saul as well.
It's easy to see ourselves as victims.
We have to be honest with ourselves.
And see that we are more like Saul than we
want to admit.
the difference is how
or if
we seek the Lord.
I'm sorry.
I had to do that.
But as I studied and prayed through this this was
one of those lightning bolts that hit me.
And I was deeply convicted.
that
I have definitely been the Saul and someone else's story.
And that's not right.
Sometimes I lose sight of my
faith.
And I become the attacker.
instead of
acting like David and crying out to God.
Okay back to happy thoughts.
In verse 1 and 2 David views God
as his savior his helper the upholder of
his life.
and he trusted
in God and in God alone to
be just
but David didn't just view God as
his savior or rescuer or his get out
of jail free card.
He also believed he was his Lord.
You see for salvation. We we don't
only receive forgiveness.
for our sins
or
Jesus says our savior, but we
also receive Jesus as our Lord.
Read first Samuel 23 for yourself. David didn't
decide for himself.
He asked God what to do.
God directed his steps.
And because of this David worshiped the Lord.
And he gladly gave an offering to it.
As I studied for Samuel in the psalm. I saw
something in David's prayer that I think is actually missing in
mine a lot of the time.
David asked the Lord Lord. What do you want?
How do you want me to act?
And God answered him.
Now what it seems like in this text is that
David heard the audible voice of God?
And got a response immediately.
But the text doesn't actually say that but that's what
it seems like.
It might have been an immediate voice of God moment.
Or it might have been a day.
a week
a month
Even longer we don't know.
What we do know is that David expected an answer?
And he had no conditions on that answer. His hands were
open.
Lord I will do what you ask.
See changing what I asked
for. That's actually the easy part.
Being willing to wait for the answer.
With no conditions and open hands and
an open heart for God to say
what he wants me to do.
That that's a challenge.
That's difficult.
for us
As Christians this means we have to
see Jesus as Lord.
Not is the magic grantor of self-centered wishes.
And this brings us to Verses 4 and 5.
And David has issued a confession of his
faith.
Behold God is my helper. And the Lord is the upholder
of my life.
Here David makes a change in
the tone of this psalm.
He seemingly stops to acknowledge God as the upholder
and the sustainer of his life.
David is declaring that God is the one who does for him
what he cannot do for himself.
He's in a vulnerable state.
He's trapped.
His enemies are bearing down on him.
And he is powerless.
To stop Saul's attempts to kill him.
He can't talk or fight his way out of it, and he
recognizes that this is all in God's hands.
We say that a lot don't we it's in God's hands.
But how often are you actually in a situation where it
is really in God's hands.
It's David reminding himself and us that
this is the nature of God. He is
the one in control and he is
upholding Our Lives by his will.
He's saying his tone seems to go beyond just a
casual reminder to summon up
the courage in the to have
confidence in God In This Moment.
He actually seems to Delight in the truth of it all.
It's a joy for him to be able to have full confidence
in God.
I think about how little I go beyond
merely knowing that God is in control but truly
delighting in it.
That's a true work of the Holy Spirit.
As for me to be able to Delight.
In the fact that I'm not in control.
God is
I'm in his hands.
Everything in US wants to fight and scratch and
Claw for control of our own lives.
But David, he's demonstrating that there's
a restful joy in trusting God fully.
Even when evil is coming for you.
If you belong to God.
Nothing can change that.
If you have trusted Jesus to be your lord and
your savior, then he is both your savior
and your distress.
And he is your lord.
Over the outcomes of the challenges of your life.
I'm going to say that one more time. He is your savior in
distress and the Lord over the outcome
of the challenges of your life.
God is in control of it all.
every minute
every detail
all of it.
In verse 5 it says he will return the evil
to my enemies.
In your faithfulness put an end to them.
You see evil wants to come for us all.
If we belong to God evil wants what God has.
Evil is literally born into us.
Through the as descendants of the first man Adam.
But when you read your Bible and you watch closely.
You'll see that God always prevails always.
David knows this
As Christians we're probably kind of uncomfortable with verse
5.
Doesn't the Bible tell us to turn the other cheek
and pray for our enemies.
His first seems to go directly against that.
David is declaring that God will destroy his enemies.
It just seems wrong and vindictive.
But if we look closely at what David's actually saying he's he's
asking God to do something. He's not
asking God to do something that's out outside of his
character. He's actually asking God to act according
to his character.
You see God is the writer of wrongs.
Why else would he take the penalty for
our sin and rebellion and
wickedness?
Why would he take that on his own son?
Sacrificing him to die a sinner's
death.
just to write the wrongs that each one of us are guilty of
David is asking God to act in accordance
with his faithfulness and Truth.
Romans 3:21 through 26 says but now
the righteousness of God has been manifested apart
from the law although the law and
the prophets bear witness to it.
the righteousness of God through faith in Jesus
Christ for all who believe
For there is no distinction for all have sinned
and fall short of the glory of God and are
justified by his grace as a
gift.
Through the Redemption that is in Christ
Jesus whom God put forward as a propitiation
or a substitute.
by his blood
to be received by faith
This was to show God's righteousness.
because
In his Divine forbearance. He had passed
over former sins.
It was to show his righteousness at the present time.
So that he might be just and the justifier
of the one who has faith in
Jesus.
You see God made, right?
the greatest wrong
in all of human history
sin
He wiped it out.
by the blood of Jesus
he wiped it out by the blood of Jesus.
for all those who have faith in him
because of the character of God David has
complete confidence that the Lord only has
his good in mind. He has complete confidence that
the Lord will deliver Justice in his
way and in his time.
the righteous way
our last section points us to
David's promise to worship
verse 6 says with a free will offering I
will sacrifice to you.
I will give thanks to your name. Oh lord for it
is good.
As David is anticipating.
The victory over his enemies he
is consumed with gratefulness that drives
this deep need to worship His rescuer.
His worship begins with a free will offering this
isn't some pre-prescribed offering.
It's an offering that is produced out of
his desire to worship.
He didn't have to do it. He wanted to do it.
David is worshiping God for something that God hasn't even
done yet.
David is also sharing his story of
Deliverance with God's people.
So that they can worship together.
And celebrate God's victory.
Because he knows that joining together in worship will
bring greater glory to God and it
will encourage the faith of God's people.
David is worshiping God based on
his name.
Remember how God is referenced in Verses 4
and 5?
helper upholder sustainer of
his life deliverer of Justice
He is worshiping God.
Not based on what he is done, but what
he will do.
It hasn't happened yet.
He's worshiping God just for who he is.
These verses are describing.
the who of God
not just the what?
David's worship is also driven by his confidence
in God.
His confidence in him as rescuer.
Because of what God has done for him in the past.
You remember a story called David and Goliath?
Once again David defeated a foe who
was by all accounts.
an actual Giant
and David was this little guy with a
slingshot?
and yet
he defeats the Giant.
David no, stranger
to God delivering victory
No matter what the odds.
Or the evil that stacked against him.
and this
is fuel for his worship.
No, we've seen David cry for
help.
We've seen him confess his faith and we've seen
him worship God.
For us as Believers, this Psalm
is a reminder.
It's a reminder that we can and we should have
confidence in Jesus Philippians 2
9 and 10 says therefore God is highly
exalted him and bestowed on him the name that
is above every name so that
at the name of Jesus every knee should
bow in heaven and honor and under
the Earth and every tongue confess
that Jesus Christ is Lord to the glory of
God the Father.
Satan will use the ungodly to
threaten our faith and all that we hold
dear.
This Psalm is the reminder that God Alone
holds the keys to Victory.
He holds the keys to victory over sin.
over evil
and even death
God will crush the enemies of his children.
Sometimes God's victories.
over our enemies
They come quick.
They seem immediate.
Sometimes they're going to be slow.
and even some
they may come after death.
After we're gone.
But he will always Deliver Us.
But he's going to do it in his time and his way.
But it's always going to be for our good.
When we are faced with trouble and are desperate for Rescue.
We can have confidence.
to boldly
cry out
in jesus' name
we can pray for him to deliver us
for from our enemies.
after all
Jesus taught us in Matthew 6:13
to pray
Deliver Us
From the evil one.
We can also.
Call to our memory.
all the examples
of how God has delivered his people
Moses in the Red Sea Daniel from the Lion's Den
Shadrach Meshach and Abednego from the fiery furnace.
Paul too many times to count
and Peter who Peter from drowning
and so many more
the idea is this
God is our savior. He's our rescuer.
He's Our Redeemer.
He's also our Lord.
And he's in control.
If you're like me, you're quick to forget.
You're quick to forget the ways that God is delivered you.
Maybe we should think more often.
About when God has delivered us.
When he's preserved us.
and when he saved us
for those of you who may not have a saving relationship with our
Lord.
Just yet. You're still seeking still asking
questions.
I would offer you this.
This Psalm is a perfect.
example of the good news of Salvation that
Jesus offers to those who
receive it
we're all in trouble and surrounded by the consequences of
our very own sin.
But God through Jesus Paid the death paid the
penalty.
For sin for my sin and
for yours.
He provided a way to be rescued.
by God once and for all
just like David.
We are all in a desperate situation because of our sin.
every one of us
Jesus is the only one who can save us.
If you'd like to know more about how Jesus can become your
lord and savior find one of our elders or our
staff or or maybe even if you came with
somebody have a conversation with them ask the questions.
I'm sure that they would love to talk to you.
As we close and the band is going to come out. I want
us all to do something together. Okay?
You can put away your Bibles.
And I'm going to have everybody bow their
heads.
I want each one of us to take some time.
Just a minute.
and reflect
on a time when
God is rescued you.
Bow your head close your eyes.
Focus your attention on God
it might have been your moment of salvation.
It might have been when he delivered you from addiction.
It might have been from physical danger or emotional Danger.
or
maybe you're under attack right now.
And you need his help.
Thank God for how he's delivered you.
and remember
that you can ask God for deliverance from your
attacker.
And you can have confidence that he is going to deliver.